PROFESSOR DAVID WEITZ:
All fluids have viscosity.
Viscosity is the resistance
of a fluid to flow.
The more the resistance,
the higher the viscosity.
Think of walking through water.
As you walk through water,
the water puts a force on you
and prevents you from
walking through it.
But now, think about
walking through honey.
It's even more difficult. Honey is
much more viscous than water is,
and it's much more difficult
to walk through honey
than it is to walk through water.
The fluid puts a force, or a
stress, that prevents the flow.
The stress is the viscosity
times the rate of flow,
or the rate at which the
fluid flows over itself.
Here's the formula for the viscosity.
The units are stress times
time, or pascal seconds.
And there are many culinary examples.
The simplest, of course, is water,
which flows much more easily than oil.
Water is much less viscous than oil.
But oil has a viscosity that changes
very strongly with temperature.
If you increase the temperature,
the viscosity of oil
decreases quite substantially.
In fact, if you heat it up enough,
it can become as low viscosity
as is water.
Many fluids have a very strongly
temperature-dependent viscosity,
and we use that in cooking very often.
To understand viscosity
from a more molecular view,
let's look at this little cartoon.
The fluid is made up of
many, many molecules,
and the molecules are
constantly moving around.
But in order to cause
the fluid to flow--
like this-- we have to cause the
molecules to move over one another.
In fact, for the fluid to
actually flow, the molecules
have to exchange places with each other.
And so the viscosity depends on how
fast they change places with each other.
So the viscosity is given by
the density times the speed
of the molecules times their size.
It's just a measure of how fast the
molecules move over one another.
And you can see immediately
that larger molecules
take longer because they have a longer
way to go to move over one another.